and as you have been analyzing david the
game between magnus carlsen and daniel
dubo actually finished with a win for
minus and that means magnus carlsen is
the winner of
watchful day one congratulations magnus
thank you all right so uh it started uh
perfectly for you today uh what has it
been like for you
um yeah uh
it's uh it's a bit funny that uh it
started
uh pretty similarly to uh
to to the other match we we had and then
um
the second game was also was also a draw
um
with some chances for both sides and
then um
and then uh then i lost the third so um
clearly uh
the emphasis today was uh to play to
play a good solid game in the
in the third and i think um yeah i
managed to manage that i quickly
got um i got a nice edge and i don't
think he had i had any chances after
that
so so how much has actually what
happened in everything's master is in
the quartz finals
sort of been in your head and been a
part of your preparations for today
uh no certainly uh
uh this was not an ideal uh
pairing for me um considering what what
happened
last time um but
yeah every every tournament is a new one
so i thought
um just need to need to focus on
on um i'm playing well and um
but uh this is only a job half done so
it's it's uh it's a big
day tomorrow as well and i don't don't
take any
anything for uh for granted um but is it
though even if you're saying it's not an
ideal matchup but is it actually
a great opportunity for you to get a
revenge after what happened in air
things and just
put that whole thing behind you for good
no the thing is that i
don't put these things behind me
so uh like i could win the match
but that doesn't make up for the one
that i
that i lost it just means that i i i
won that one so um
yeah i it's uh
it's not going to be easy tomorrow
that's regardless of what happened today
i think
tomorrow will be will be tough yeah well
i mean
daniel duval with his crazy style always
sacrificing these pawns
how will you prepare what will be your
focus tomorrow
um we'll certainly prepare but i'll be
um yeah i'll be ready to be uh to be
surprised for sure i think
she has something in store for me sounds
good magnus thank you for joining us
good luck tomorrow thank you mike oh
sorry mike
nah sorry david okay i was just going to
ask his opinion on that
yeah because sometimes he is sitting
there looking at it right yeah and
i'm sure he'd love white's position
right now but i would have yeah it'll be
interesting to know what he thought
about the winning chances
i wanted him to be the deciding vote you
know do you play
critical move first or do you maneuver
and uh yes
sorry my bad i was too quick there david
sorry um
but i mean you are one of the top
players in the world david so getting
it's a oh actually i think magnus is
stellar maybe magnets
i thought you were still talking to me
okay sorry uh i know i think
in general uh it's more likely that
white's going to win than that this will
be uh will be a draw
yeah now we were wondering and what's
the what's the ideal endgame strategy
here
do you go for the kill immediately or do
you as david advocates maneuver maneuver
maneuver until your opponent is short in
time or perhaps you're yourself short
time as well
and then go for the kill yeah i know
david david will
will uh wait till he sh he's short in
time and then
but maybe too well like this uh
no yeah i think it's uh if you don't see
a clear way
you uh try a couple of minor things
first
and then and then go for your main plan
yeah
okay and yeah i agree good chances for
white but
um what would the winning plan be do you
see anything immediate or
are we in for another 50 moves of
suffering for duda
no i don't see anything immediate maybe
he didn't need to play f5 all those
moves back
so he he could potentially go uh
uh g5 and after everything's exchanged
there you get a nice square for the king
on e5
so maybe uh uh f5 obviously looks
uh looks quite tasty but maybe uh
um maybe that was a little haste uh
hasty but i i still believe he has good
winning chances though
all right sounds good firstly so thank
you for your thoughts magnus and good
luck tomorrow
thank you